my name is Justine ezarik or iJustine
for those of you guys online my name is
Jenna but on the Internet I go by um
it's me Jenny eighty planking to me is
really an art form actually it's really
not an art form at all because all you
do is lay down straighten your arms
straighten your legs and that's that's
blanking newspaper biking is super
popular everyone in the entire world
knows what planking is um she's planking
it's good where you just lie down places
and you just kind of plank my feet
Lincoln yes yeah there's a guy he's
coming to crowd you can post it on
YouTube Oh No
yeah just eaten my plank a lot and it's
funny because I actually started posting
pictures on my Facebook page of me
planking and then she one is outdo me
and post better pictures of her planking
so kind of turned you this big
competition of us like who can out plank
the other oh yeah you want to plank you
have a plank off well guess what watch
this plank did you see that you see that
plank so we've kind of just been going
back and forth it's like a friendly
competition it's really friendly
competition it's friendly but I've
mention that it was friendly I'm
flanking all day and right now I'm kind
of at a standstill
at a plank blank a plank leg isn't you
just don't know what to plank that's me
right now that's me right now I'll play
you know I think people plague because
they're bored
I think there's a lot of legal issues
with planking like you probably can't
plank in someone else's yard or a plank
on places that are not public property
you can plank in front of a police car
but planking on top of a police car and
you don't think that's that's
recommended I can't really say if
planking is legal or not it's such a new
phenomenon that I don't really think
rules have been made about planking yet
I know I heard in one of the videos that
it's not illegal but you can get cited
for trespassing trespassing
yeah flanking has actually made me a
better person
it's made me able to think more clearly
make me have more friends and overall
I'm just generally a much more happy
person I'm trying to do a serious
interview here you see this sino-soviet
I hope you guys enjoyed our video thanks
so much for watching now we have a
little project for you we made a
planking music video but we want to
feature you guys planking so be sure to
send your planking pictures to the email
address below and of course we're not
legally responsible for any injuries or
any arrests made while planking mm-hmm
plank safely
chokes ah ha ha ha your finger is like a
juniors play Bobby no more shimmying
Jenna Sasha you told me to write that
sound was okay how's the sound love you
tastic but how do I look you look good
Oh